wir schalten jetzt einmal zu meinem
kollegen paul ronzheimer in die ukraine
nach kiew ich hoffe es schon da bislang
höre ich ihn noch nie da ist er ja paula
es dauert ja doch danach ein wenig du
bist einer der letzten journalist live
in der ukraine und bericht ist paul dir
mir damals unseren film a 8 zu schauen
auch versprochen dass wir dranbleiben
und deswegen danke dass du auch heute
für ein kurzes update zur verfügung
steht wie ist die lage vor ort
janina am sonntag sind wir acht wochen
also zwei monate hier mein team und ich
verdiene jorgos montag ist der fotograf
und ich als reporter aber das was wir in
den letzten drei tagen gesehen haben in
butter das hat wirklich noch einmal
alles übertroffen an dramatik an tragik
an toth den wir schon in den wochen
zuvor gesehen haben dort über die straße
zu laufen menschen zu sehen die gerade
kartoffeln geholt haben und dann fahrrad
gefahren sind und dann erschossen wurden
menschen zu sehen die mit
verbundenen händen auf dem rücken
erschossen wurden menschen zu sehen in
einem auto ein teenager mit seinem vater
wo sportmedaille in diesem wagen laden
erschossen ein rentnerehepaar hundert
meter weiter dort auf diesem verlassenen
feldweg wo wir sie zufällig entdeckt
haben erschossen ich glaube es ganz
wichtig dass wir weiter über butscher
sprechen dass diese bilder gezeigt
werden dass wir bei bild diese bilder
zeigen und auch alle anderen medien
diese bilder zeigen denn das was dort
passiert das sind klare kriegsverbrechen
und egal was sehr gelobt doch dort sagt
egal wie viele lügen der kreml dort
verbreitet ich kenne man nur wieder
sagen wir haben es mit unseren eigenen
augen gesehen und wenn man dort aus
butter kommt in butter gibt es kein
handynetz da hat jetzt elon musk gerade
eins seiner satellite hingeschickt aber
das funktioniert nur in einem engen
radius also normalerweise hat man dort
kein handynetz auch strom und wasser
funktioniert nicht wenn man dort raus
fährt und das ist bei mir gestern
gewesen dann springt das handy wieder an
nachrichten und ich sehe eine nachricht
was sehr gelacht sagt dass die ukraine
das gemacht hätten oder die briten oder
wer auch immer dann ist man als reporter
doch noch fassungslos wenn man gerade 15
minuten gleichen dort selbst gesehen hat
wir werden jetzt gleich erstmal vielen
herzlichen dank für den update und
natürlich auch für deinen unglaublichen
einsatz werden gleich über ein thema wir
sprechen susanne gaschke wird das
vorstellen von der welt und zwar
toxische männlichkeit die ja eigentlich
auch dir vorgeworfen wurde wegen dem
wieder angezogen bist an der front wirst
du diese debatte in deutschland
wahrgenommen bevor wir sie gleich jan
tisch debattieren
ich habe viele debatten der letzten zwei
monate als völlig absurd gesehen viele
konnte ich mir gar nicht zu gemüte
führen weil wir keine zeit hatten weil
wir eben hin berichtet haben aber man
merkt dann schon etwas für ein ich will
nicht sagen hätten aber wohlstand
satten land wie in deutschland leben das
wir uns bestimmte debatten leisten
können wenn es hier einfach nur um eines
geht um leben oder tod
bei vielen herzlichen dank dass doch
heute abend uns wieder informiert hass
und wir hören uns dann morgen abend
wieder dankeschön und
dazu kommen wir dann susanne zu dem
thema mit der toxischen männlichkeit ist
natürlich kein einfacher übergang jetzt
nachnamens bewegen den worten ich finde
der noch wichtig dass wir das thema
debattieren aber er hat natürlich recht
es geht um leben und tod und zwar leben
und tod für die ukraine und man fühlt
sich schon manchmal
also wirklich erschüttert über was wir
hier schon banalitäten verhandeln und
insofern ist natürlich auch
eigenartig mir ist halt nur aufgefallen
in den vergangenen tagen und das hat
mich also zunehmend irritiert und wir
müssen ja auch damit umgehen also ja wie
wird nicht damit umgehen können
offensichtlich dass wir eine eine eine
unerträgliche unerträgliche situation
mit ansehen müssen und offenbar nichts
tun können darüber können wir ja
vielleicht auch noch reden ja warum das
so schwer ist ich habe der bauch bei
jedem sagt dann muss die nato jetzt rein
und der kopf sagt aber das gibt einen
atomkrieg
in europa jedenfalls sehr wahrscheinlich
und deswegen geht es nicht aber das ist
ja das zerreißt einem das herz insofern
ist es ist es etwas abwegig aber die
diskussion wird hier trotzdem geführt
und das finde ich so ihre also ja eine
spiegel kollegin eine kolumnistin
schreibt also ernsthaft über den mutigen
tapferen präsidenten selensky dass der
so im westen verehrt wäre werde das sei
ja also irgendwie ein schlimmer hinweis
dass man jetzt toxische männlichkeit
also doch wieder gut finde und
eigentlich sollte ein mann doch auch
angst zeigen können und und ich glaube
weinen können oder so ich weiß jetzt
nicht dass das was sie wörtlich
geschrieben hat aber allein der gedanke
diese beiden dinge in verbindung zu
bringen und dann ist eben ja auch bei
uns hat leider leider auch von kollegen
des öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunks
wieder vorgeworfen worden also mit
seiner art von berichterstattung also in
der hand dran am krieg würde er
sozusagen eine toxische männlichen
männer wegen der weste und
wahrscheinlich also die mandatsträger ja
da selber nicht erschossen wird und das
macht einen natürlich in einer
unglaublichen weise fassungslos wenn man
davon toxischer männlichkeit reden kann
dann ja wohl bei den russischen soldaten
die sozusagen zivilbevölkerung
hinrichten und die vergewaltigung gegen
frauen als kriegswaffe einsetzen was
sozusagen ein gut erforscht das mittel
ist also das haben dass männer armeen
immer getan das ist fürchterlich und das
muss man kritisieren und nichts anderes
und mir ist einfach aufgefallen an
diesem beispiel noch mal in etwas von
einem furchtbaren zustand der die
diskussion über die feministische
debatte bei uns über die frauenbewegung
bei uns eigentlich ist also das war doch
mal eine vernünftige veranstaltung die
gesagt hat so also frauen müssen in der
gesellschaft doch alles können und
dürfen und werden können was männer auch
können und dabei darf ihnen nichts im
weg stehen und selbstverständlich müssen
wir alle uns wehren gegen sexuelle
übergriffe oder gewalt in konkreter form
aber inzwischen sind wir doch bei einem
generalverdacht also gegen den alten
weißen bösen mann und dabei fällt denen
dann ihre weise sie lenski ein und nicht
putin ist also vollkommen irre
sozusagen den wir bekämpfen müssen der
sozusagen apriori schuldig ist da kommt
es auf den konkreten fall gar nicht an
und das ist natürlich ein machtkampf den
wir da haben unter sind also
verschiedene identitäts politische
gruppierungen hoch engagiert die die
sehen für sich einfach eine chance boden
gutzumachen und und jede opfergruppe hat
sozusagen also einfach ganz konkrete
macht und karriere ansprüche die größte
opfergruppe sind nach dieser lesart ich
teile die ausdrücklich nicht und viele
frauen teil den ich natürlich nach wie
vor die frauen und das endet dann
irgendwann damit also dass nicht etwa
die quote also eine unterstützungs
mitteln doch ist wo die männer das aktiv
verhindern dass eine tolle frau irgendwo
hinkommt sondern wirklich so eine ist
doch alles egal haltung erst wir wurden
jahrhundertelang unterdrückt jetzt steht
uns alles zu kompetenz spielt keine
rolle mehr ich kann jeden job machen und
das erleben wir leider so ein bisschen
können wir uns auch die proporz
besetzung mancher ministerien ansehen
das war vielen einer die sind trotzdem
hat alles zusammen gepasst dass es
selten aber ich finde auch alleine dass
der feminismus oder die feministische
debatte die auch mir zum teil zu
überhitzt geführt wird das thema
aufgreifen der ukraine krieg also den
krieg gegen die ukraine und dann das in
dem fall so unser kollege paul
ronzheimer weil er so ich fand das
völlig bizarr diesen bericht ich hab mir
gedacht was soll denn paul ronzheimer
tun damit er nicht männlich rüberkommt
also wer mit dem karlsruher vorschlag
hast du den gelesen der beste vorschlag
war für solltest du im lastenfahrrad mit
rosa birkenstocks und helm und
birkenstocks durch den krieg oder
vielleicht sollte sie noch einmal den
sind diese stücke schreiben über die
toxische männlichkeit selber in den
krieg als kriegsreporter ziehen die
frauen das ist ja auch möglich man kann
ja auch als frau kriegsreporter eine so
erfolgreiche kollegin ist übrigens vor
ort den zdf katrin eigendorf das jetzt
auch toxische männlichkeit machten
journalismus
wie weit ist die debatte dahin
abzudriften patricia also ich zu mir
total schwer mit diesem erstmal begriff
toxisch ich glaube den verwenden wir
jetzt nur noch also als eine schlechte
beziehung bist du unglücklich talks die
beziehung läuft sind job schlecht er ist
auch eine toxische arbeitsplatz also
irgendwie ist es alles irgendwie toxisch
geworden das scheint das modewort
überhaupt zu sein alles ist toxisch
deswegen lass uns das einfach schon mal
herausstreichen toxisch und dann geht es
um möglichkeiten dann geht es um die
frage was ist männlichkeit was darf
wendigkeit und offenbar gibt es
bestrebungen und das finde ich seltsam
und ich würde mich selbst sogar als
feministin bezeichnen ich finde es aber
befremdlich wenn männlichkeit als sich
oder das was wir bisher als männlich
empfunden haben plötzlich an takkt ag
werden muss um zu beweisen dass man
feminismus unterstützt und das
verschwimmt mir zu sehr ich verstehe
nicht warum
alte attribute ausgedient haben die wir
als männliche sehen weil wir sie uns
nicht mehr erlauben dürfen und ich
befürchte auch wir uns dann als team
verlieren und zwar als team mann frau
als team die gemeinsam sagen wir wollen
auch dinge in unserer gesellschaft
verändern das ist völlig überfällig das
ist uns allen klar da müssen wir dinge
verändern ich möchte mehr männer in
elternzeit ich möchte mehr frauen in
chefetagen das möchte ich alles sehen
aber bitte lasst uns aufhören das so zu
verscherbeln dass man es am ende nicht
mehr versteht dass selbst ich als
unterstützerin dieser sache denke
vielleicht ist es manchmal gut einfach
ruhig zu sein wolle offenbar ich
verwende eine falsche vokabel und somit
man hat irgendwann das gefühl man kann
sich nur noch in die nesseln setzen und
ich glaube das ist der sache die ich
unterstütze einfach nicht dienlich jetzt
ist es schwer sich als mann zu äußern
diese dieser talk so schnell warnt
möchte ich fast sagen aber ganz
ernsthaft und das war ja auch von
susanne gaschke gesagt wenn man paul
vorhersieht aus dem gebiet und da auch
seine seine reportage über den letzten
42 tage gesehen hat da muss man sagen
über welches thema reden wir eigentlich
gibt es einen präsidenten ob der jetzt
ein mann oder eine frau ist weiß oder
schwarz kurze haare lange haare der
stellt sich hin und will sein land
beschützen und zwar oder verteidigen
gegen ein aggressor gibt im tierreich
genug beispiele beispielsweise von
frauen also von von weiblichen tieren
die sich auch für ihre jungen stellen
das machen übrigens mütter auch wenn
ihre kinder angegriffen werden stehen
die sich in st da darfst aber ich darf
mich ganz normaler reflex dem schiebt
man immer den männern zu komischerweise
frauen können sich doch genauso gut
verteidigen und machen das auch also wo
ist das problem ist ein präsident sagte
ich und jetzt trägt er auch noch ein t
shirt also ist in kampfmontur ich
verteidige mit allem was ich habe mein
land schlafe drei bis vier stunden wenn
überhaupt die nacht und tue alles damit
mein land meine leute meine männer
frauen und die kinder die ihr leben alle
hoffentlich bald wieder in freiheit
leben können das doch irre und
vielleicht am rande sei mir eine
bemerkung nur erlaubt weil ich das eine
sehr spannende ausführung fand von
susanne gaschke diese diese gewisse mir
steht das gewisse mir steht alles zu
syndrom was ihr offenbar jetzt auch von
der feministischen bewegung immer
stärker nach vorne geschoben wird es
wird in den nächsten jahren einen
dramatischen fachkräftemangel geben wir
reden über sehr über 20 30 reden von 5
millionen fachkräfte fehlen das heißt da
ist für männer und für frauen das die
gute nachricht des heutigen abends gehen
noch platz auf spitzenpositionen da
brauchen wir keine toxischen kämpfe
sondern das regelt sich alles von selbst
wer gut ist kommt sowieso nach oben und
auch wer nicht so richtig gut ist wird
auch super job chancen haben also dass
die gute nachricht des heutigen abends
das war auch ein gewisses eigentor der
feministinnen der modernen für
ministerium die häufig solche eigentum
machen die ukraine dort als beispiel zu
nähern diese art der kleidung wird in
der ukraine als zeichen der solidarität
mit den soldaten an der front auch von
frauen getragen eine gute freundin von
mir zum ukrainischen parlament die ist
auch zum kaffee zum frühstück genauso
angekommen weil das merkwürdig aussehen
würde in zeiten in denen ganz viele
soldaten an der front sterben sich als
mann mit krawatte schick zu machen sehe
ich als frau mit bluse zurechtzumachen
dieses zeichen ist notwendig dieses
zeichen ist wichtig in der ukraine ist
das zielbild für die armee das
israelische modell bei dem auch frauen
genauso wie männer dienen sollen
übrigens auch mit einer wehrpflicht und
dieses zielbild ist gesellschaftlich
akzeptiert grad was will denn der
feminismus mehr erreichen als eine
solche art der gleichstellung bis in den
bereich hinein wo eben gekämpft wird bis
in den männlichsten beruf hinein den
beruf des soldaten
und ausgerechnet hier die ukraine zu
kritisieren ist ein dermaßen schlimmes
eigentor dass ich mich frage ob sich
jemand überhaupt mit der ukraine
beschäftigt hat aber es ist natürlich
genau so zu sagen ich weiß nicht ob ihr
untersagt oder fett gesagt hat es ist
natürlich so ein bisschen ein symptom
also es geht uns hier schon sehr sehr
sehr gut und wir haben unglaubliche
demokratische freiheiten die haben wir
in corona finde ich etwas wenig
verteidigt grundrechte und sozusagen
jetzt die vorstellung dass da ein volk
einer völlig willkürlichen kriegerischen
aggressionen ausgesetzt wird und sich
verteidigt das ist offenbar so weit von
uns weg das militärische ist so weit von
uns weg wenn das sieht man ja ein
bisschen auch an unserer
verteidigungspolitik in den ganzen
letzten also zwei drei vier
legislaturperioden
wo also menschen immer frauen die dem
ganzen komplex sehr fern standen
fachlich die sich wirklich eigentlich
für andere sachen interessiert haben was
ihnen ja überhaupt nicht vorzuwerfen ist
aber sozusagen dann also mit diesem
ganzen komplex also bundes wären
verteidigung konfrontiert waren dass wir
sehr lang zehn ich sind also ich meine
es war fast ein wunder dass scholz die
trendwende angekündigt hat und gesagt
hat wir liefern jetzt mal waffen wir
beharren jetzt nicht mehr auf unserem
gewalt ist keine lösung also wohl da die
menschen in den kellern sitzen oder
schnell schossen auf der straße dient
das war ja immer es ist sehr schwer für
ganz ganz viel und vor allem für viele
nicht böse sein sozialdemokraten ist ist
ganz ganz schwer die müssen abstand
nehmen von einer illusion der sie und
viele haben gesagt es ist eine falsche
illusion aber sie haben an dieser
illusion festgehalten diesen traum
geträumt frieden schaffen ohne waffen es
geht immer so weiter die mauer ist weg
und jetzt leben wir das geht mit
russland so und die ist eine illusion
und ich gestehe auch jedem zu das tut
auch weh wenn ein traum zerplatzt das
ist auch schmerzhaft weil man sich ja in
gewisser weise extrem selbst
hinterfragen muss über 30 jahre an die
falsche sache geglaubt so und das ist
geplatzt aber muss einfach irgendwann
dann sagen so und jetzt müssen wir
weiter und wir brauchen glaube ich
gerade deutschland viel mehr verständnis
dafür wie strategie auch militärische
strategie funktioniert und wie kampf
funktioniert so bitter das ist